come on I believe nation today we're
going to talk about how you can improve
your self-discipline have you ever
struggled to be more disciplined you
know you got that paper due next week
but you don't do anything all week even
though you know it's coming or are you
set up a brand new habit you're so
excited about that you know can improve
your life your relationships or your
work but you don't stick to it or you
started that workout routine and you got
really pumped up fired up into it you
know lost a couple pounds but then you
know three weeks later it was gone and
what did you blame you blamed your
discipline he's a guy I wish I was more
discipline and everything would be great
and the rowdy is it's true you know
discipline is one of the most important
things we can develop in our lives
because without that ability to be sort
of self-reliant and willful to get
things done on a continual basis we
never get that great amount of momentum
and progress towards what we really want
and I bet there's a lot of areas of your
life that could really benefit from
being more disciplined whether you're
eating healthier or working out more
often or being more disciplined about
doing your art on a consistent basis or
contributing or even being more
disciplined about just speaking up for
yourself when you know that you should
so how can we help you find a goal and
be more disciplined that's the topic of
this video
whoo
often times people will come to me for
advice on Fitness on building their
businesses and their relationships
whatever the case may be and often the
place that they're dropping the ball is
in bad habits or not building productive
habits because it's very difficult to
just get up and change your life just
change the way you do things people like
to say that all the time hey just stop
doing this or start doing that they like
to give advice but the the underlying
factors that our friend our individual
whoever is asking the question is not
disciplined enough to actually put that
thing in action get that thing done so
the thing that I have always told my
students and my clients is to start with
a small win begin with something small
so for example if you want to lose
weight I often tell people just start
walking every single morning don't worry
about counting calories don't worry
about complex workout ideas don't worry
about anything that anyone is selling
you just get up and walk every morning
right now it's not the walking that's
actually going to make that person
successful now it will add to your
success because getting up and walking
fresh air and exercise it's going to
support you in losing weight but we all
know that there's far more factors to
consider but what it will do is create
the virtue of discipline commitment
right commitment and discipline sort of
go together and the fact that that small
win associated with getting up every
single morning is under your belt you're
going to feel the courage the confidence
and you'll have the ability to begin
adding other things to your ability to
grow stronger so now that you know it's
been 60 days 90 days and it's like you
got that pattern
down pat you get up every morning you
just walk that's it you don't think
about it it's become a habit you now can
use that tool of creating habits and
instilling discipline with the next one
which should be a little bit more
advanced perhaps only drink water with
your meals don't drink any soda don't
drink any juice just drink water that's
the next one and then the next one
becomes more complex and the next one
becomes more complex now it might seem
like this is tedious and slow but I
guarantee you that after 90 days of tiny
winds and the revamping of your
character you will be the type of person
that can get anything done at any time
and the longtime perspective is going to
be a successful one for you start small
have big wins with these little things
and then use that new version of
yourself that new character tool to
attack bigger and more advanced things
until you reach your goal now once
you've decided on the discipline you're
going to develop the key is for you to
launch strongly on your new discipline
resolve to never allow an exception
until it becomes permanent if you fall
off the wagon immediately restate your
affirmation as a command to yourself and
begin trying it again this is the only
way you can develop the habit of
discipline in that particular area the
best part of this process of developing
disciplines is the direct relationship
between self-discipline and persistence
the more you persist in any endeavor the
greater self discipline and self
confidence you'll develop it's been well
said that persistence is self-discipline
in action the more consistently you
practice your chosen disciplines the
more you will like and respect yourself
you will feel more confident and
optimistic you'll become more effective
in every area of your life well you've
gone from looking out of windows at
classrooms to having a very regimented
timetable on the weekend so how did you
develop such a good self-discipline I
don't know I am very disciplined that's
all I can say - very very disciplined a
creature of habit
what's that thing that Goods it called
OCD or something again if you look at my
desk you'll see all the pens lined up
like that and piece of paper over here
and the cup over there and all that so
I'm just very disciplined that's it and
I think in business and in life I've
worked on the work on the principle of
clear my desk every minute or every day
and so answer emails immediately answer
people's questions immediately that's
been my success in running my company
that I'm there to like a springboard if
you like for employees to tell me what
their issue is and then to give them a
quick resolution or to it so they can
get on and deal with it so that's my
discipline and I would heartily
recommend it to all of you if you decide
to become you should be disciplined you
should discipline yourself because it's
not a bad way of life I've never met a
person who was not successful that
didn't have a great amount of
self-discipline within their life
self-discipline and being able to
perform and being able to keep your life
on schedule and being able to keep
commitments and promises and meet
deadlines is essential to success of
none of us none of us can afford to have
a life that is controlled by someone
else or a life that is basically
controlled by our emotions I learned
many years ago that there are two kinds
of people there's the type of person who
says I'm going to wait till I feel like
it before I do it and then there's a
person who says I've got to do it so
that I feel like it one will never get
anything done because they're sterile
waiting to feel the moment to move when
the other person says no I need to move
and then I will begin to feel the moment
Sonia self-discipline is essential in
your life and in my life if we're going
to get things done so I have a challenge
for every one of you this weekend the
chow
just simple as you go through your
weekend and sometimes it's kind of a
hopefully an easier time of your week
ask yourself am i practicing
self-discipline in my life am i doing
the things that I should do because I
need to do them or am I kind of waiting
to feel the moment do like our friends
Nike say just do it you gotta set up
some social rewards you know it's hard
to say disciplined it's something if
you're never getting any payoff from it
you know we can take that first step I
told you about about visualizing
something but if you get some small wins
along the way and you're never
celebrating with other people then your
brain says ah this isn't benefiting me
and I really mean that you have to do
with other people you have to have that
that that that connection with others to
celebrate to keep your will intact
to keep doing the thing you're supposed
to be doing it's so important for you to
do this you know if you're a writer and
you know you finish a chapter
call up a friend say hey you know I
finish the chapter I'm supposed to
finish today let's go out for a drink if
you've if you've accomplished something
at work you said you were gonna do get
everybody together say hey you know what
lunch is on me today let me take care of
you guys for lunch if you'd finally
achieved something that you've been
working towards for so long you need to
take some time to go out with friends
and family and just talk about the
process talk about them how it felt to
finally complete this thing see if we're
never celebrating we're never going to
develop real discipline and it's funny
because too many people think those are
opposite things they think discipline
can't be fun that the discipline can't
be joyful but the Masters of this life
have proven that doing things in a
disciplined way can also be doing things
in a joyful way and if you think
discipline has to be this hard awful
terrible thing maybe
you're never going to have discipline
because you're constantly trying to fool
yourself and doing things you don't want
to do and it's time to find the things
that you do want to do so my quick take
on this I see two things one I like
having a schedule I like having a
routine I like having a calendar I like
having a list of habits I like having a
schedule for what I'm going to be doing
every day and I live and die by my
Google Calendar I think it's really
important I think it keeps me on track
it keeps me focused keeps me somewhat
regimented and I like that I like that
self-discipline that didn't poses on me
I think the other side of the coin
though that a lot of people don't pay
attention to is you have to love what
you're doing you have to love the
process because you can only force
yourself to do things that you don't
like for so long if you hate the idea of
working out or going to you know make
those cold calls or creating content for
YouTube if you hate doing it you can
create a calendar and a schedule and a
routine you can put it on Google
calendars and you can say I have to get
this done every day and you'll do it for
a certain amount of time but at some
point you know you can only do something
that you hate for so long before
something breaks before something gives
and you have to change and so yes the
schedule and the tools can help you but
at the top you have to actually love
what you're doing and if you don't love
it then find another way to stand find
something that you do love find stuff
that makes you come alive because it's
way easier to say disciplined about
something when you love the process and
not just the end result
so thank you guys so much for watching
we made this video because dice rolling
asks us to so there's a topic you'd like
us to cover in the next addition to
believe life leave it in the comments
below and we'll see what we can do
I'd also love to hear which of the
points that you heard this video had the
biggest impact on you what changes
you're now going to make in your life
for business because of watching this
video really curious to find out if you
want to leave a comment below and one
last thing my goal is to get a million
subscribers on this channel so anything
you can do to help out to share it with
friends tell people about it
tweet it put it on Facebook out of the
playlist whatever you can think of I
really truly amazingly appreciate it
thank you guys so much for watching and
have an amazing day continue to believe
I don't see you soon
self-discipline carried Wilbur and
Orville right through a multitude of
phasers and enable them finally to give
the world its first practical airplane
an achievement which has made the world
smaller and change the entire trend of
civilization self-discipline helped
Helen Keller to triumph over deathless
blindness and dumbness a combination of
afflictions such as most people never
experience self-discipline helped me to
carry on through years of heart aching
discouragement and defeat and give the
world the first practical philosophy of
success based on the know-how gained by
hundreds of men and women who spent a
lifetime by the trial-and-error method
in discovery of the principles which
lead to personal success self-discipline
is among the top ranking features of all
the great religions including of course
the Christian faith and there are some
people who believe that our major
purpose on earth is that of developing
wisdom through struggle and
self-discipline one thing is certain
no one ever becomes very wise without
the aid of self-discipline and no one
ever finds peace of mind and happiness
without the strict exercise of
self-discipline self-discipline is the
only means of transmitting sorrow into
faith it is the only means by which we
may transmute hatred of others into the
milder emotion of sympathy for them it
is the only means by which we may reveal
and profit by the seed of an equivalent
benefit which comes with every adversity
and every defeat it is the only means by
which we may shut out of our minds the
deadly effects of past experiences of
suffering and unpleasantness and it is
the means by which we may discover that
other self we carry around with us that
self which has great
capacity for belief and does not become
influenced by failure and defeat
self-discipline can give us freedom from
the fear of death the most difficult to
master of all of our fears it can free
us from the disease of hypochondria
the fear of imaginary illness with which
so many people suffer and sometimes die
self-discipline is the means by which we
may think our own thoughts live our own
lives as we wish to live them and remain
forever free from the evils of fears and
limitations which we have inherited from
the dark ages before the dawn of
civilization care more than normal and
more than necessary about your results
that's it learn to care start developing
inside of you this this adamant feeling
this desire to care more than normal and
more than necessary about the results
that you want you see most people don't
cross the finish line with their goals
and their dreams not because they don't
have the ability or the resources or the
relationships more often than not it's
because at some point they allow
themselves not to care more than normal
and more than necessary just think about
an example in your own life when you
decided to take action on some desired
outcome but ultimately you gave up on it
you'll notice if you're honest that at
some point along the way you allowed
yourself off the hook because you gave
yourself permission to no longer care
you see having the conviction about your
outcome about your result is so powerful
and it is enacted when you allow
yourself to care about that result more
than normal and more than necessary you
see when we allow ourselves to care more
than normal and more than necessary that
something becomes a priority in our life
in his book the power of habit
Charles Durack talks about the science
of small wins and in a nutshell he just
says in order
be successful at creating a new habit
you must allow yourself to experience
small consecutive wins that support the
behaviors you want
I call this winners momentum when you
decide to care more than normal and more
than necessary about your desired
outcome even if you don't even believe
in that moment that you're able to
accomplish it just by caring having the
conviction about the small little steps
along the way creates a winner's
momentum that ultimately catapults you
across the finish line and before you
know it you're winners momentum is
looked upon by other people as
discipline I tell people you overcome
laziness by having a goal like there has
to be something greater than the
laziness so so if you really want to do
something bad you're going to do that
instead of chilling
better than you want a party you don't
want it as much as you want to be cool
you most of you don't want success as
much as you want to sleep some of you
love sleep more than you love success
and I'm here to tell you today if you're
going to be successful you've got to be
willing to give up sleep but if what you
want to do is not as important in sleep
then you're gonna sleep yeah you don't
wanna press a net you've got everyone it
as bad as you want to breathe